tech merci monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur jacques myard
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre ministre des affaires
étrangères je voulais vous je suis
admiratif de votre courage pour succéder
à celui qui a mis la france hors jeu sur
la scène internationale votre mission
est quasiment mission impossible si vous
continuer dans la voie tracée de
l'idéologie et des posture moralisatrice
comprenons nous bien monsieur le
ministre
comme le souligne max gallo un homme de
gauche mais réalistes les droits de
l'homme
on est tous pour mais ce n'est pas une
explication du monde surtout quand on
fustige d'un côté et de manière
sélective et que l'on est sourd et
aveugle de l'autre avec l'arabie
saoudite en exemple pris au hasard
oui la france est en jeu au
proche-orient et où la tournure des
événements cela vient d'être appelé
prend une dimension tragique et hyper
dangereuse avec notamment la politique
aventureuse de la turquie à l'égard des
kurdes et de la syrie la syrie où votre
prédécesseur salué devant la presse
le bon travail d'anne nostra sic et re
sic a nostra filiale d'al qaïda la syrie
où nous nous privons par idéologie de
sources de renseignement contre les
terroristes de l'état islamique
notre ennemi en raison de l'absence de
relations diplomatiques avec damas quant
aux sanctions contre la russie croyez
vous qu'elles feront plier moscou alors
qu'elle pénalise nos intérêts alors mes
questions sont simples
allez-vous réexaminer notre politique
étrangère à l'égard de la syrie et de la
russie dans l'intérêt bien compris de
nos intérêts mais aussi de la nécessité
de trouver des solutions politiques à
ces conflits qui n'ont que trop duré
en renonçant aux services et aux
postures idéologiques n'a pas le cas
monsieur jean marc ayrault ministre des
affaires étrangères et du développement
un canadien
un député jacques myard je vais pas me
lancer dans un exercice théorique
simplement l'objectif il est clair il
faut que la guerre en syrie cesse et
donc ça passe effectivement par un
engagement international et vous le
savez très bien et qui exige en effet
une lucidité et aussi une à sens des
réalités
il faut parler avec tout le monde et
vous avez parlé de la russie mais bien
sûr que nous parlons avec la russie nous
parlons avec la russie pour la situation
en ukraine
nous parlons avec la russie ou la
situation en syrie mais en même temps
nous avons des exigences et ses
exigences
aujourd'hui c'est le respect des
engagements qui ont été pris à munich
la russie comme d'autres partenaires
sont engagés à l'arrêt des hostilités à
l'arrêt des bombardements pour l'accès
aux aides humanitaires et ce n'est quand
même pas faire du centralisme du
sentimentalisme ou du droit de
l'hommisme que me dire qu'il y à des
millions de personnes qui aujourd'hui
sont sous les bombes et 6 ans n'ont pas
de solution alors ils n'en n'ont qu'une
c'est de fuir et de devenir des réfugiés
alors oui il faut être clair il faut
être ferme l'engagement est pris et bien
bien sûr qu'il faut discuter avec tout
le monde y compris avec la turquie
ce que nous faisons en bonne
intelligence nous nous disons les choses
y compris de ce qui s'est passé il ya
quelques heures
mais nous voulons aussi aider ces pays
la jordanie le liban je rencontrerai le
ministre affaires étrangères
dans quelques instants c'est le sens de
la conférence de londres avec 10
milliards d'euros dead 3 milliards
venant de l'europe dont une partie ira à
la turquie une partie à la au liban une
partie à la jordanie
si nous voulons trouver des solutions
pour les réfugiés qui arrivent
massivement
alors oui il faut se battre avec
détermination pour arrêter les
bombardements apporter l'aide
humanitaire et puis engager un processus
politique de négociations qui doit
reprendre à genève le plus vite possible
merci monsieur